what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime pro and man what an amazing
black clover chapter this was
so good not just because we actually got
to see osta and liebe's devil union form
after a lot of teasing from tabata but
more than that
we got to see who asta really is as a
person
yet again we saw osta who in the eyes of
the nobles is just a lowly commoner born
without magic
and tainted by the power of a devil
emerging as the fearless savior
of the clover kingdom and honestly the
reactions of the other characters to
osta were just as awesome as what
austa did to that ancient demon
this chapter gave me goosebumps in the
best way possible so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the blacklord
content and you want to see more in the
future
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second
but it helps a lot and no i'm not just
saying that it really does help with the
youtube algorithm
and if you're new to animeopro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
please make this the video that you
subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
the only way to make sure that you won't
miss future videos is to go through the
trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting that option that says
all
finally this video will of course
contain black hover manga spoilers we
are talking about the latest events in
the manga
so please proceed with caution you have
been
warned so after the wizard king julius
damnatio kira and many others tried and
failed
to defeat the ancient demon who was
attacking the clover kingdom capital
asta steps up to the plate he was able
to use his anti-magic to negate
that massive magic attack that the
ancient demon was preparing to launch
at the capitol and everyone who
witnessed this incredible feat was
instantly shocked by the extent of
asta's power
but one person who wouldn't be surprised
at all is
asta's biggest rival you know back in
the spade kingdom
as xenon is talking smack about how the
other ancient demon is going to destroy
the clover kingdom
yuno just smirks and says that
unfortunately for xenon
and the ancient demon asta is still
there
in the clover kingdom this one brief
moment
shows just how much faith yuno has in
his rival
and his best friend asta and honestly i
thought that this little quick moment
was
actually great do not make the mistake
of underestimating our boy osta because
as his greatest rival
yuno would never make that mistake asta
then
finally reveals his new devil union form
and it looks freaking awesome asta looks
like his entire body is covered in dark
armor and he seems to have additional
devil lines
on his face all of his teeth are now
super sharp
just like liebe's and the anti-magic
energy around him looks different
and more powerful he now also has wings
and horns
on both sides of his body symbolizing
the fact that when he unites with liba
in this new form asta is complete
however we quickly learned that this new
form still has at least
one major limitation as of right now
asta and liba can only stay inside
this devil union for about 5 minutes
but just when you think that this might
hurt asta's chances of actually
defeating the demon
something so freaking epic happens asta
declares that hey
it's all good because they'll just take
down the ancient demon
immediately 5 minutes who needs five
minutes
meanwhile once they see asta's new form
the people of the capital begin worrying
that maybe this
devil magic user is also a bad guy who
is working together
with the ancient demon after all most of
these people who are witnessing the
fight
against the ancient demon have zero
understanding of devil magic
and they know nothing about osta as a
person so they immediately jump to the
conclusion that all devil magic is evil
and that every devil magic user is
inherently dangerous
but the people who know asta know that
he is not here to hurt the clover
kingdom
he is here to save it i especially want
to give a big
shout out to klaus who despite being a
noble
publicly screams out his support for
asta in front of
everyone he tells asta that he can do
this
not because he is possessed by a devil
but because he is a real
magic knight osta embodies the true
spirit of a clover
kingdom magic knight more than anyone
else
klaus then screams go asta
and i have to say that in this moment i
literally got
goosebumps it was just so great and
while so many others
inside the capital are scared of asta
because of his devil magic
and while so many others look down on
him for being a commoner
the nobleman klaus goes out of his way
to encourage asta
in front of everyone way to go klaus and
i hope that many other citizens of the
clover kingdom will
follow in his footsteps osta then tells
damnatio to watch as he
saves the clover kingdom together with a
devil and asta then uses the demon
slayer sword to absolutely slay
that ancient demon like for real
asta literally cuts the demon's body in
half with a single swing
of the sword the ancient demon is at his
core
a massive chunk of magic power that
reflects
any other magic and that is why he is so
hard to defeat for
any magic user even the most powerful
ones
but asta's anti-magic is something else
altogether
it is not magic in the traditional sense
so that is why
it is super effective against the
ancient
demon it slices through his overpowered
magic body
like it was butter the people of the
clover kingdom cannot believe their eyes
and neither can guimodello and asta
declares that now is the time for him to
invade the spate kingdom
and take the fight back to the dark
triad
wow what a chapter now of course
seeing asta's new devil form was great
our boy
is finally complete he has finally
unlocked his full potential
thanks to his brother liebe and now they
can both
avenge their mother together it is both
epic
and poetic and i loved every minute of
it
that said i think i might have enjoyed
everyone's reaction to asta saving the
kingdom
even more than the new form itself it
was just so cool to see
klaus encouraging osta in front of
everyone
it was great seeing julius fawning over
osta's incredible new power
and it was pure joy seeing damnatio and
the other nobles react to being saved by
a lowly commoner who uses the power of a
devil this is the same devil possessed
commoner that they put on trial
and wanted to execute and yet here he is
now
rescuing all of their noble asses
so good please let me know what you guys
thought of this chapter
did you love it as much as i did this is
probably my top 10 favorite chapters
in black clover it was just so epic and
so poetic
at the same time is the ancient demon
really dead already
and if so what does this say about the
extent of asta's new power
if mario leona herself had to keep
fighting that other ancient demon
after he kept getting up and yet osta
can take
this demon out in literally three
seconds does that mean that asta has now
surpassed the level of even the
strongest
magic knight captains or is this just a
matter of anti-magic being a lot more
effective than fire magic
against these ancient demons personally
i don't think that asta could take
merolona in a one-on-one at least not
yet but
anti-magic is clearly more effective on
demons and devils
so asta will definitely end up being the
mvp of the climax
of this arc either way last time
this kind of ancient demon showed up in
the clover kingdom he had to be put down
by the first
wizard king himself so if asta just
succeeded in taking out a demon like
that on his own
or rather together with liebe but
without the help of anyone else
then asta's power has already reached
legendary status
there is no doubt about that finally did
you guys like asta's new form
and what do you think about the 5 minute
time limit
is this time limit going to pose a major
challenge for asta
in the future i can definitely see it
becoming an issue because the tree of
cliffhoth contains a bunch of different
devils of the highest tier
dispersed on different levels so
osta probably won't be able to just take
them all out
at once he will surely need more than
just 5 minutes
whatever happens though i'm extremely
excited to see the rest of this
arc unfold this just keeps getting
better and better and i'm here for it
110 percent if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want us to keep it coming
with the blacklover content please leave
a like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord tuigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
liam thompson
al-jatal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life canal
baked buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally
thank you to all of our pro-hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
rathune deyora alicia octa bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew crews and
anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you